most of us are used to the idea of an
actor getting a role and you know acting
the part will even accept a stunt double
for scenes where the actor needs to jump
out of a plane but for the most part if
we're watching Gary Busey we want to see
Gary Busey wait why do we want to see
Gary Busey again as it turns out we're
not always watching who we think we're
watching and that happens much more
often than we realize there have been
plenty of times when actors were swapped
out and us and the audience never even
noticed Natalie Portman the heebie kiss
between Thor and Jane Foster in Thor the
dark world post-credit scene is one of
the steamiest moments in all the Marvel
movies and with good reason
actor Chris Hemsworth isn't making out
with his co-star Natalie Portman the
scene was shot after principal
photography had wrapped and Natalie
Portman was unavailable Portman told the
New York Daily News I couldn't get there
because I was working on my own film and
so they put his wife in my wig and
costume that's why it was so passionate
yep
Hemsworth was locking lips with his
real-life wife Spanish actress and Fast
& Furious star Elsa Pataky the
switcheroos certainly saved a lot of
trouble for the crew while filming other
kissing scenes in the Thor series
Portman said that since she's so short
they usually had a rant for me to walk
up so I could land somewhere near his
face because that's the only way to make
this turn into something like this Bruce
Lee after Bruce Lee's untimely death on
July 20th 1973 one of his greatest
passion projects was left unfinished
game of depth of which Lee had already
filmed about 40 minutes five years later
director Robert Klaus picked up the
pieces and was forced to create a brand
new plot using leaves previously film
scenes shots from older Bruce Lee
projects and even footage from leaves
real-life funeral in addition archival
film Klaus also hired stand-ins to play
Billy lo Lee's character in the new
version of Game of Death in Klaus is
Game of Death blow both receives plastic
surgery after a brutal fight and later
fakes his own death and wears the
disguise making it easy for Klaus to
replace Lee with other actors although
some parts weren't exactly
seamless well sitting right there by the
telephone just waiting for you to call
patience that's not one of our virtues
Michael Pitt it's hard to imagine anyone
more villainous than Hannibal Lecter but
the TV series Hannibal gave us just such
character in Mason Verger as the
sadistic Meatpacking tycoon Boardwalk
Empire star Michael Pitt spends the
latter half of the show's second season
tormenting the other characters
it delivers a terrifying performances
virtue showrunner Bryan Fuller called
The Joker to Hannibal's Batman
so while Mason Verger returned in season
3 Michael Pitt didn't Joe Anderson took
over the role and had to spend the
entirety of the season covered in heavy
prosthetics
fortunately Anderson's vocal performance
was flawless
resulting in a seamless transition
between the few actors all right
I can talk fresh fresh Nicholas Brendon
Nicholas Brendon appeared in all but one
episode of Buffy the Vampire Slayer and
yet surprisingly he wasn't the only
person to play Xander Harris but the
geeky pal and perennial punching bag
Brendan's twin brother who uses the
stage name Kelly Donovan often took
Brendan's place when the actor wasn't
available or when Buffy's supernatural
shenanigans required more than one
Xander on screen at once Donovan made
his most memorable appearance on Buffy
in the fifth season episode their
replacement he in which demon creates a
second Xander who threatens to take over
the originals life in the episode
intervention Donovan replaced Brendan
entirely during some action scenes when
Brendan had pneumonia and couldn't come
to the set Gene Hackman it might be hard
to imagine now but in the 70s only one
big-budget superhero franchise ruled the
silver screen even before the first
Superman film became the breakout hit
director Richard Donner was already
working on a sequel unfortunately during
filming Donner clashed with producers
Ilya and Alexander saltine about the
film's budget and although Donner had
filmed roughly 75% of Superman - during
production of the first film he was
replaced by a hard day's night Richard
Lester in order to secure a director's
credit Lester we shot quite a bit of
Donner's footage substantially changing
Superman 2 story and tone in the process
the way the salkinds treated daughter
didn't sit well with the cast reportedly
Christopher Reeve was openly furious
about Donna's dismissal according to the
book Superman vs. Hollywood Gene Hackman
who played Lex Luthor in both films
flat-out refused to show up to finish
shooting Superman - with Hackman absent
Lester in the salkinds were forced to
use body doubles and voice and person
aiders just to finish the movie Josh
pence in 2010 army hammer made headlines
and picked up a couple of awards for his
portrayal of identical twins Cameron and
Tyler Winklevoss in the social network
but he couldn't have done it alone on
the set Tyler was actually played by
Gangster Squad star Josh pence later
hence his face was digitally replaced
with hammer
by the special effects team in order to
prepare for the dual roles hammer and
pence attended a twin bootcamp where
together they worked out each twin
brothers particular quirks and
mannerisms and while Vince's career
hasn't taken off like hammers he's
become more positive about his social
network experience over time Josh Dallas
for such a small role Marvel Studios
sure had a lot of trouble casting band
role the dashing feeis Guardian warrior
first Chuck's are Zachary Levi with sets
play to go t discard Ian but had to drop
out with NBC ordered more episodes of
Chuck's third season next Marvel cast
Queen of the Damned star Stuart Townsend
in roles but Townsend departed shortly
before filming due to mysterious
creative differences
Marvel eventually found its founder
Elana then unknown actor named Josh
Dallas who finally brought the classic
character to the screen but the trouble
didn't stop there
between Thor's premiere and the start of
filming on Thor the dark world
Dallas landed the role of Prince
Charming on ABC's fairytale drama once
upon a time because of once upon a times
rigorous shooting schedule Dallas
couldn't join his fellow warriors for
their big-screen return and Marvel
needed to recast the part their choice
Zachary Levi of course who was finally
free to take the role perhaps the next
time we should start with the big one
Penelope Cruz
Monica Cruz had been an accomplished
dancer and actress for years and while
she's had featured roles in several
foreign movies she's probably most
famous in America for her part in
Pirates of the Caribbean on Stranger
Tides in which she played her sister
Penelope Penelope took over from Keira
Knightley Rob Marshall's 2010 sequel and
played the part of Angelica Jack
Sparrow's love interest while filming
though Penelope learned that she was
pregnant
in order to minimize the risk -
Penelope's unborn baby
Marshall hired Monica who looks a lot
like her older sister to serve as a
stand-in in an interview with The
Telegraph Penelope said I did a couple
of months of training and did what I was
able to do but I couldn't do everything
just what was safe Monica came at the
end to do some scenes
she's a dancer and very good with the
sword because she's done a film herself
neither Penelope nor Monica returned in
Pirates of the Caribbean
dead men tell no tales but the crews
family is still a big part of the
franchise
Javier Bardem Penelope's husband plays
the film's lead villain Lena Headey at
Cersei Lannister Lena Headey plays the
ultimate villain on HBO's Game of
Thrones so viewers watched with a bit of
sadistic glee when the character was
literally and figuratively dressed down
and then for aided through the streets
at King's Landing in nothing but smears
of filmed the scene is intense and
humiliating and drawn-out so the
audience can experience or awkward
humiliation the craziest part however is
that were not even watching heavy in the
scene the entire walk is performed by a
body devil seamlessly merged with
Hetty's facial expressions and body
language to make one awkward horrible
walk to the red key Brandon Lee the son
of legendary martial artist Bruce Lee
said charming and talented Brandon Lee
was set to take Hollywood by storm sadly
while filming his breakout role in The
Crow Lee was shot by a prop gun that
added dummy round left in the chamber he
died later at the hospital to complete
the film leaves friend and stunt double
sheds to health key stood in for him
while special effects were used given
Lee's face meanwhile another stunt
double helped finish out some of the
action scenes the result is a movie in
which leaves roll was perfect and
there's no indication of the tragedy
that befell him jennifer aniston friends
was a massive success and Jennifer
Aniston is arguably the biggest star at
Purdue which makes it all the more
unusual that it took years after the
show is off the air for someone to
finally notice an episode where Aniston
inexplicably disappears a fan watching a
friend's marathon happen to notice a
strange scene and the one with the
mugging from the ninth season Aniston is
standing next to Matt LeBlanc except
it's not Aniston at all it seems that
Aniston stand-in was on the set that day
and for whatever reason her scene wasn't
edited to remove her from the shot the
presence of a stand-in isn't such crazy
thing after all
stand ends are on set to replace actors
when they're not available it's just
that they usually don't end up in the
final cut
Shemp Howard the three stooges were
under contract to produce eight films in
1956 unfortunately four films into their
contract
chef Howard died of a heart attack at
age 60 and in the 1950s no one gave it
damn if you died or not your contract
needed to be fulfilled and thus was born
the fake shem producer Jules wife said
about producing four brand-new films
each starring chef by cutting together
old footage with new themes featuring
joël Palma an actor who had long filled
supporting roles in the Stooges films
they just filmed him from behind or with
his face obscured by shot we're in here
we got a lot to do so che hai
hold your horses with it the deception
was so obvious that its legacy still
lives on today the cast of evil dance
the term fake Shemp was actually coined
by director Sam Raimi because he needed
to use quite a few of them during
production of Evil Dead at star bruce
campbell recounted in his memoir if
Chin's could kill because the film was
so ultra-low budget Raimi and the actors
couldn't always work on the same
schedule Raimi needed a film what he
could when he could and with whom he
could this meant no fewer than eighteen
stand-ins were used during production
that's pretty incredible as the end
result shows no sign that so many extra
people were involved even though the
film is still notoriously ridiculous
Harrison Ford on the set of Indiana
Jones in the Temple of Doom
Harrison Ford suffered a pretty severe
back injury that sidelined him for
several weeks of filming Steven
Spielberg however was prepared for any
eventuality board was swapped with his
longtime stunt double dick Armstrong
Armstrong acted so much like Ford that
he managed to confuse Spielberg on set
more than one a number of action scenes
were filmed without forth including the
epic fight between Indy and the massive
warrior on the mine conveyor belt thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to